( intro music )
Four years ago I was
standing in front of a group
of local fishermen
on a tiny island called Mitiaro
in the Cook Islands.
And I was there to tell them why
they needed to protect sharks.
Except there was one problem.
They hated sharks.
Sharks stole fish
from their lines
that they needed to
feed their families.
So, these are the guys
that I had to try to talk to
who had very real
experiences with sharks.
They're in canoes every day
trying to feed their families
and sharks are literally ripping
the tuna off of their lines.
And, so when the man
who's sitting behind me
in the turquoise shirt
he raised his hand, told me
how much he hated sharks.
He literally said like,
"I hate them.
They've terrorize me
in my canoe.
I wish they would all
disappear from the planet."
I'm like,
"Oh, this is not going well."
And then he said, "But
I've learned something today.
I wasn't sure of the
importance of them to our reef.
I have children,
I have grandchildren
and I would like
for them to fish
and for that reason
I will support you."
For me, that was the single
most powerful moment
of the entire two years
of the campaign.
And soon after that happened...
( audience laughter )
We made front page of the paper.
This small group
of farmers, fishermen
voyagers...
They came together
and were successful in
getting regulations
that ban the
import, export, sale, trade,
possession and trans-shipment
of sharks and rays
in the entire exclusive economic
zone of the Cook Islands.